[Music]
he's been in the music business for more
than 38 years and sold more than 100
million albums with his group kiss he's
here today to speak with me Paul Stanley
of KISS welcome to you it's great to be
here more than 3000 licenses you own in
partnership with gene Simmons
more than a hundred million albums sold
over a half a billion dollars in
merchandising sales since 1973 was that
division when you were a kid in New York
with Gene Simmons was that your vision I
think the vision was always to be the
biggest the best and to stand on the
shoulders of the bands that we looked up
to in one sense we wanted to be the
Beatles we wanted to be for individuals
where people could love the band
collectively but also find a favorite
member
[Music]
certainly we we never and I have never
wanted to follow ranked I wanted to
start my own parade and of course you
were known for the makeup the star on
your eye and the star child as they
called you where did the concept for the
makeup come from we were in a time where
there had been this great British
Invasion where bands look terrific and
when you saw a band invariably you knew
that a member of the stones wasn't in
the Beatles because the Beatles looked
one way the stones looked another way
all bands seemed to have their own
calling card as far as identity we
wanted to take that a step further and
the makeup seemed like the perfect way
for each one of us to come up with a
character that symbolized and embodied
us as individuals now that being said no
individual and band could have come up
with their makeup without the other
three members there there was a synergy
you know that made all this happen and
when you had the makeup did you really
have anonymity well it's a funny
question because people think that off
stage it was Clark Kent and Superman and
we could just go walking around and the
truth of the matter is it probably
worked to my advantage because I could
separate myself and say there's me off
stage and me on stage and and the look
is different but you know if you see a
guy walking down the street who's six
foot plus with black hair down to here
and platform boots you go either he's a
member of kiss or the circuses in town
so uh anonymity no but being able to
separate myself yes and now when you
look at the music industry now all of
these groups are fighting to have the
same kind of presence that kiss had
because the sales have slowed down in
the music industry
when you look back at that period was
the merchandising bringing in more money
than the music itself at any period not
for us
they all went hand-in-hand together it's
very very tough
any ban now - let alone succeed but make
any kind of money there's just less
money available
record companies blew it when they
didn't stop sampling and file-sharing
and all this other nonsense before it
got out of hand
so now record companies are scrambling
to basically put bands into slavery so
that they can make the money that
they've lost it's unfortunate because as
much as somebody who's aspiring to be a
successful musician might want to say
I'm just doing this for the music when
they can't pay their rent they're going
to think well the money also helps and
at some point you're going to need you
know the money to fund your career and
to keep it going forward and I just want
to clarify when you talk about record
companies signing artists into slavery
that you're probably talking about 360
deals in which they sign a contract
which allows the record company not only
to get the the revenues from the album
but also everything else the
merchandising the touring and everything
else that they do sure you become an
indentured servant it's it's it's
unfortunate and it's the record company
trying to make up for their lack of due
diligence when they could have saved
their own hides you know this whole idea
that's propagated that people are
file-sharing things like that are
absolute nonsense you can't share what
you don't own I can't say I'm sharing
your transportation and steal your car
you know it's it's a great sounding term
but this whole idea of mass distributing
something that somebody doesn't have any
rights to is insane or trying to back it
up by saying I or someone else have
enough money that it shouldn't matter
let me be the one to determine that I
worked my butt off to get to where I am
and I'll set the ground rules so what is
the solution for record companies I
really don't know at this point I don't
know what the future holds
I worry more about the the band that
don't have the same access to the public
and who if they have a chance to put out
product or are shackled in so many ways
that that pot of gold isn't there for
them and that's very important at some
point you need that financial security
it's very good to say I'm in it for the
music but it's the music business and if
you're not in it for everything if
you're not even for the business there's
somebody who's as talented of taking
your money as you aren't making it
you're not wanting to be pigeonholed
the fact that we're sitting around your
work and your art that you're constantly
when you're not recording music creating
these these beautiful pieces of life is
a testament to that tell me about your
art I started painting about 10 or 11
years ago and I was going through some
personal problems and interestingly a
friend of mine who knows me very well
said you should paint and I don't know
why that resonated with me I went out
and bought canvasses and paints and
brushes and palette knives and all all
that you would go by in an art store
although I didn't know how to paint
really yeah the only rule I had was no
rules I didn't know what I was doing the
only limitation was the edge of the
canvas whatever went onto the canvas was
a way for me to get in touch with myself
I never had any notions or aspirations
to do art shows you'd even sign your
first painting no my first painting
which is hanging in the house was not
signed and not signed to this day
because it's a reminder to me of how
this all started but when I did put it
up it was amazing how many people would
come over and say who did that painting
it was very interesting when I started
doing art shows the pieces were selling
at a tremendous rate and people were
connecting with the art that's what's
important success to me is only a way to
measure your connection to the public
if you're doing something right it
connects I live by something I call the
law of commonality which basically says
in short speak people have more in
common with each other than differences
and if you can tap into something in
yourself into a need in yourself
fulfilling that need you will fulfill a
need in other people so by painting and
by painting truly and solely to please
myself I knew that there had to be other
people out there who would like it if
you try to second-guess the public you
may wind up kicking yourself and saying
I should have done it my way so if you
just follow your own gut and your own
intuition you'll usually land on your
feet so I define myself by the the
challenges I take on and usually I do
pretty well and you you have done very
well you haven't allowed people to put
you in a box and you know even coming
out here and and seeing your life here
you have four kids you are a painter
you're a musician and you're not ashamed
to call yourself a businessman what what
to be a businessman does not go against
ethics you know if you're an ethical
person if you're a moral person if you
have a conscience if you're involved
with the world if you're involved with
charity business maybe the key to it all
that's that's how we get to give back
you know I think we heal ourselves by
giving success without giving back as
success that's unwarranted
how long did it take for you and gene to
get ownership of your careers to really
have ownership
we were always savvy enough to be aware
of what was going on around us we've
always been and I've always believed
that you have to be diligent and
vigilant you know most people succeed
once and if you don't take advantage of
that success you'll be one of those
whatever happened to stories on vh1 so
it's you know I can't stress enough that
it's really not just about music when
you talk 360 I just go of course
the 360 deal is mine because I created
everything why would I be giving that
away to people who had nothing to do
with it often if we need an outlet we
can find the outlet whether we make a
deal with a large retail chain we're
luckily and thankfully at a point now
where we don't need a record company
we can bypass the record company and go
immediately to retail and in 2009 you
had a record called sonic boom that went
to the top of the Billboard charts after
all of the years that you've been in
this business but you also did a lot of
touring you did some touring in support
of that album then you did another tour
in 2010 and 2011 more touring
now you have this new album coming out
you'll do a touring about for that album
tell me about that how important is that
for a band like kiss I think for a band
like kiss but more specifically for kiss
it's very important to tour because
after our longevity and how long we've
been successful we actually become more
proactive a better term immortal by
going it back out there when we go on
stage and you see the band 30 years
later and say they look the same they
sound better it makes us more into
superheroes and we've always been I
would liken us to Superman with a guitar
we're superheroes who
also play music so anytime we step out
on that stage mouths are a cape because
you look and you go my god that's kiss
and kisses timeless and ageless and
should be and let's face it there aren't
too many bands out there that have been
able to consistently do sellout tours
Rolling Stones maybe Aerosmith Motley
Crue some of your contemporaries are
still out there doing this stuff but the
super band concept is that something
under the new economic model that you
can see happening for bands in the
future will we see big bands like that
again more than ever there is a need for
those super groups and that's why people
keep gravitating back to them when you
see a band that's been around you know
what you're going to get when you go to
see kiss there's a guarantee that you're
going to get your money's worth you're
seeing a band that has built its craft
over thirty five years when we first
started out you started as the opening
act at or two later you became the
second act by the time you headlined you
damn well knew how to headline nowadays
the downfall of a lot of bands is that
they have a hit album and aren't
prepared to go play an arena and
shouldn't be it takes time to learn that
craft so you may buy an album buy a new
Act the chances of you spending
hard-earned money to go see them versus
going to see something that's
tried-and-true
I'm betting on the tried and true band
and and that's why people come to see us
I want to hear you say and you've been
able to put out music and consistently
still be at the top of the Billboard
chart but when you look at the top ten
consistently now and over the past year
or so a lot of it is dance music and
dance music is also starting to impact
the sound of some of these other genres
including rock-and-roll R&B and soul
music what is it going to take to keep
rock-and-roll alive rock and roll is
alive and very healthy whether or not
it's found on the charts in in the
numbers that it once was we certainly
are not suffering at all
interestingly sometimes people talk
about the 70s being like our big years
and it's it's laughable those years are
eclipsed by multitudes by the business
we do now in the last 10 years we've
been on the cover of Forbes
so it has transcended being rock music
but nonetheless whether you look at a u2
or stones or McCartney rock and roll is
alive and well I don't know that there's
room at the top quite the way they once
was and I think that a lot of this the
dance music is expendable quite honestly
because it's interchangeable you can
virtually take any one of those tracks
and take one of ten singers and put it
on and it doesn't really change it so is
it successful yeah is it serving a
purpose absolutely will it stand the
test of time the genre might but I don't
think that necessarily most of those
artists will does it bother you that
most of the artists are not playing
instruments I'm bothered by very little
at this point in my life you know I I
find it troublesome that when people go
to see and act live they're not seeing
some
live there seeing it live I should
correct it they're not hearing it live
is that person up there dancing around
absolutely are they singing not a chance
is the band playing hardly you could
virtually have the band walk offstage
have the singer walk offstage and just
keep that music playing so that's
bothersome to me only because I think
people deserve more people deserve more
than just a show they deserve passion
they deserve real sweat they deserve
commitment and that's the kind of music
I grew up listening to so I think that
the people miss out they may enjoy it
but there's a lot more to be had you
mentioned being on the cover of Forbes
you and your partner Jean have really
kind of taken ownership of this
ownership concept not necessarily always
the mythology of a rock person to think
about business in the way that you that
you have done it but you've been out
front in terms of the vision for kiss
and in crafting the business strategy of
kiss and probably so and why is that
because I think that the caricature of a
rock musician or a rock star is folly
it's um it may appeal to the critic or
the journalist because they get to live
vicariously by seeing somebody living
dangerously or stupidly but it's usually
things that they would never do
themselves I think it's it's it's sad
and I would rather further the notion
that music and business go hand in hand
because if they don't somebody else will
be making your money for you so I don't
think that it negates or takes away from
the commitment or love that I have for
music the fact that people want
merchandise and the fact that we're the
most merchandise band in history I take
a lot of pride in that when other bands
might have a problem with it
quite honestly at the end of the day
it's because they're jealous
they do well to figure out what makes
kiss so appealing the fact that they
want a t-shirt with me on it versus some
guy who looks like the boy next door you
know maybe you need to glam up a bit you
know do something that that's
interesting and then you should read the
rewards it really reminds me of Kurt
Cobain who obviously was a leader of the
grounders movement but he was very much
so involved in the business as much as
his persona I kind of projected that he
wasn't he very much was well it's funny
because when you look at some of the
quote unquote heroes of credible rock
and roll and what-have-you
you see somebody on stage and torn-up
jeans well those torn-up jeans are a
costume just like I wear a costume when
they get on their private jet they're
not one of you they're not you know
they're not going home in a van you know
they're multi multi millionaires no I'm
an entertainer in the proudest sense of
the word and I'm also a businessman in
the proudest sense of the word there's
money to be made and a damn well deserve
to go into the pocket of the guy who
made it when we wrap up I really want to
ask you about the future you have this
album that you're producing with kiss
2012 at or tell me what you see the
future looking like for the kid or
kissing for Paul Stanley my future is
like the last 10 or 15 years of my life
or 20 years of my life it's a story I
couldn't write better you know it is
something that I've worked at but it's
it is the American dream on all levels
the success I'm married to an incredible
woman
I have fabulous children and I have this
career doing what I did in school
because I loved it I played guitar in
bands when I was in junior high school
I'm still doing it today I am still
drawing guitars on paper only now
they're manufacture
you know now there's 13 million dollars
in sales of guitars that I draw life in
the future will be more of the same it's
um there's this great foundation that I
built that kiss is allowed that will
stand for anything that I choose to put
on top of it I'm just building this
monument but it's really a monument
maybe to the public so my life is really
about polishing the diamond you know
it's my life is a gem
so anything at this point is just a way
of making it Sparkle more whether it's
the next kiss album which is arguably
going to be the best album we've done
why because we're a band now of four
guys who get along great
who are geared towards making the band
great you can't succeed at your best by
saying how can the band make me more
successful you have to think how can I
make the band more successful what's
best for me will will play out when the
band is more successful is that
something that you knew when you started
out or did you have to learn that over
the years you learn that over time you
learn it the hard way I think you you
learn what a great partnership is and
what a great working relationship with a
band is to me a great working
relationship is based on knowing what
its limitations are if you don't expect
something from someone that they can't
give you you'll never be disappointed
the key to a great relationship is
keeping it realistic if you want
something that that partner can't give
you get it elsewhere spoken like a true
band leader of one of the most
successful bands in the history of the
world thank you so Mike you posh van Lee
from kiss thank you